♪
>> LET ME FIRST UNMU MYSELF.
GO MORNI,
YALE CLEGE CLASSF 2021.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WELCOME TO THE GRADUATES OF
ACE HOPPER, JONATHAN EDWARDS,
TRUMBULL, SILLIMAN, AND EZRA
STILES COLLEGE, WHO ARE ARRIVED
ON OLD CAMPUS TBEGIN
OUR CEREMONY. AND WELCOME TO
FAMILY, FRIENDS, AND MEMBERS OF
THE CLASS WHO ARE JOINING US
VIRTUALLY TODAY VIA LIVESTREAM.
WE ARE SO EXCITED TO HAVE
ARRIVED AT THIS SPECIAL DAY. IN
A FEW MOMENTS WE WILL BEGIN
ANNOUNCING THE GRADUATES AS
THEY
PROCESS ACROSS THE COMMENCEMENT
STAGE HERE IN FRONT OF ME.
BEFORE WE START OUR PROGRAM, A
FEW WORDS ABOUT THE LAND ON
WHICH TODAY'S CEREMONY IS
TAKING
PLACE.
YALE ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES AND NATIONS,
INCLUDING MOHEGAN, MASHANTUCKET
PEQUOT, EASTERN PEQUOT,
SCHAGHTICOKE, GOLDEN HILL
PAUGUSSETT, NIANTIC, AND THE
QUINNIPIAC AND OTHER ALGONQUIAN
SPEAKING PEOPLES, HAVE
STEWARDED
THROUGH GENERATIONS THE LANDS
AND WATERWAYS OF WHAT IS NOW
THE
STATE OF CONNECTICUT.
WE HONOR AND RESCT THE
ENDURING RELATIONSHIP THAT
EXISTS BETWEEN THESE PEOPLES
AND
NATIONS AND THIS LAND. THANK
YOU, AND PLEASE ENJOY THE
PROGRAM.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> OKAY.
MR. PRESIDENT, I
HAVE THE HONOR TO PRESENT
CANDIDATES FROM TRUMBULL
COLLEGE
FOR THE BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN
YALE COLLEGE. WHEN THEY HAVE
BEEN RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY
OF YALE COLLEGE AND APPROVED BY
THE CORPORATION, DEAN CHUN WILL
ASK YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT TO
CONFER UPON THEM THESE DEGREES.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT PETER SALOVEY:
BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME,
I
SHALL CONFER UPON YOU THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN, AND SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU
TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
JEFFREY ZHOU
THE BANNER BEARER
CLAIRE LAMARRE
MARCUS HAO-YI SAK
OBED KWASI ASHIATEY ABABIO
DONALD CHARLES AHRENS III
TIFFANY BOLADE AJUMOBI
JACOB DEAN ASHER
GIANNA ELENA BAEZ
JEREMY EMMANUEL BARON
SARAH BRAKEBILL-HACKE
SAMUEL CLAYTON BRIGHAM
DARRION COLBY CARRINGTON
CAL LAWRENCE CHRISTOFORI
DAYLE DAHAE CHUNG
CALEB ADAM COHEN
VINICIUS J. DA SILVA
AKSHARA DHADDA
CECILY XIAOXI GAO
HANNAH ISABELLA GELLER
LAUREN ANASTASIA GILLINOV
XINWEI GUO
YASHASVINI JINDAL
ZEYNEP KARACAN
ADIA MICHAELA KAIN KLEIN
HUNTER JANE KOHN
KATHRYN JANE KOZEY
TAHJ PHILLIP LAKEY
ABIGAIL MARIE LEONARD
ALAN LIU
HANNAH SIGNE MANZ
MITCHELL LOGAN MARES
CELIA ISABEL MARTINEZ-ACEVES
JACK THOMAS MATTEI
GABRIELLA SOFIA MENCIO
RIYA MITAL
CAROLINE CATHERINE MOORE
JEWEL E. MOORE
VISHNU MURALE
JONATHAN MURILLO
GRANT DOUGLAS NEAGLI
OBIDIKE NNOROM, JR.
MAX BYERS OBMASCIK
ILAYDA ORHAN
JIYOON PARK
RUCHIRA RAY
ZYRIA J. RODGERS
MARIKO FUJIMOTO ROOKS
MELVIN ROUSE II
NICHOLAS ANDRES RUIZ-HUIDOBRO
MAGDITS
DANIEL SANCHEZ
JOHANNA SHEN
JEREMY ROBERT IRWIN SONTCHI
RICARDO AARON SOTO
CHARLES BROOKS TANANBAUM
GRIFFIN COOLIDGE THOMAS
RODNEY LAMONT THOMAS
JARED GUANG-CHENG TRUONG
PETER THOMAS AQUINAS
VANDERSLICE, JR.
AVA ANTOINETTE VANECH
ANUSHKA WALIA
ANGELICA MARIA WALKER
ALEXANDER MICHAEL WHITTAKER
ADAM DAVID WOLNIKOWSKI
CHRISTOPHER MING XUE
ERIC W. YOUSHAO
JINGJIA JERRY ZHOU
BENJAMIN WALTER ZOLKIEWICZ
CONGRATULATIONS TRUMBULLIANS.
!
[ APPLAUSE ]
JULIA ADAMS:
MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE HONOR
TO PRESENT CANDIDATES FROM
GRACE
HOPPER COLLEGE FOR THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE. WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY OF
YALE COLLEGE AND APPROVED BY
THE
CORPORATION, DEAN CHUN WILL ASK
YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT TO
CONFER UPON THEM THESE DEGREES.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
[
.
>> BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN
ME, I
SHALL CONFER UPON YOU THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN, AND SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU
TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SHELDON ZHAO
THE BANNER BEARER OF GRACE
HOPPER COLLEGE.
JAU TUNG CHAN
AND
MEGAN SIMEI XU
THE PROCESSION MARSHALS OF
GRACE HOPPER COLLEGE.
ABDAH HAROON ADAM
MEGAN MARIE AHERN
AIA ALVAREZ NISHIO
KOFI ANSONG
MALIK MARKANE BARNETT
MARY ELIZABETH BARNETT
RYAN ELISABETH
BENSON
ALMA MAIA BITRAN
SEUNGKYOON ANTONIO BONG
TIMOTHY CARTER BRADLEY
ELEAZAR CAMEZ
KO LYN CHEANG
XINYI CHEN
PATRICK ANDRÉS CHERRY
RACHEL ALLEGRA COHEN
JOHN HARMON COOPER
ROBERT SEBASTIAN CRYSTAL
FORMOSA DEPPMAN
SAMUEL HARRIS ESSIG
RILEY ANN EVERSOLE
JULIEN MATEO FERNANDEZ
INDIRA AMANI FLORES
CHARLES BERNARD FOSTER
DREW GALLS
NEEHAAR JAYESH GANDHI
MICHAEL EDWARD GARVEY
LAUREN GATTA
ZACHARY JASON GOLD
VIVEK YADHU GOPALAN
MEHER HANS
VALENTE HERNANDEZBAUTISTA
YVONNE HO
ROBERT JAMES SHEARMAN HOWARD
JJ HOWLAND
CHARLOTTE ANNE HYLINSKI
TALUS GARDINER IORIORONEK
RAYSHAWN ANTOINE JOHNSON, JR.
OLIVIA DANIELLE JORASCH
SAMUEL WEILLER LANDINO
SOPHIE ELSPETH MORTON LATHAM
PAIGE JULIA LAWRENCE
MELISSA LEONE
MARLIKA YORVOLE ALTAGRACIA
MARCEAU
MICHAEL MARTINEZ
JOHN KRISHAN BIR MAYPOLE
JULIA CATHERINE MCCLELLAN
DALIA HANA MOALLEM
MATTHEW SCOTT NADEL
JULIA R. NADELMANN
LARISSA HANA NGUYEN
CRYSTAL LYNN NIEVES GARCIA
ZOE ELIZABETH NUECHTERLEIN
ALEJANDRO NUNO
DARRELL LUISMANUEL PONA
DEANCARLO PERSEVERANDA PUTONG
ANSHUMAN RADHAKRISHNAN
REESE R. ROBERTS
NISSIM ROFFE
D. MAJOR ROMAN
MIRIAM AVIVA ROSS
ANNIKA KAARINA SALMI
KATHRYN WRIGHT SCHMECHEL
BRANDON DAVID SCOTT
SHAIMA BHUIYAN SHAMA
CHIARA NICOLE SPAIN
AAROHI SRIVASTAVA
SIMON LEE STONE
ERIK KENJI TAKADA
TEAVA MARCO TORRES DE SA
LIN THANDAR TUN
RIANNA MARIE TURNER
ALONDRA OLIMPIA VÁZQUEZ LÓPEZ
CLARA VILLAÇA RENAULT PENTEADO
NANCY KATHRYN WALECKI
ERIC WALLACH
CARLY DUNIA WANNA
CORY WU
VIVIAN YI
AMBER PASCHAL YOUNG
JORDAN CRAIG YOUNG
DANIEL ZHAO
AND THE GRADUATES WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY MARY
ELIZABETH BARNETT
FAITH CHEROTICH CHUMO
PAUL STELBEN
CONGRATULATIONS GRACE HOPPER
COLLEGE CLASS OF 2021!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
MARK SALTZMAN:
MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE HONOR
TO PRESENT CANDIDATES FROM
JONATHAN EDWARDS COLLEGE FOR
THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE. WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY OF
YALE COLLEGE AND APPROVED BY
THE
CORPORATION, DEAN CHUN WILL ASK
YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT TO
CONFER UPON THEM THESE DEGREES.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT PETER SALOVEY:
BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME,
I
SHALL CONFER UPON YOU THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN, AND SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU
TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CHRISTINA FERANDO:
ANNA J. SUN
THE BANNER BEARER OF JONATHAN
EDWARDS COLLEGE.
CHIMASOKA-CHIKA VICTORY
OGBEJESI
AND
STEVEN DANIEL ORIENTALE
THE PROCESSION MARSHALS OF
JONATHAN EDWARDS COLLEGE.
FIONA AILEEN ASBURY
EKATERINE BAKRADZE
JACEY CACAL BALDOVINO
DARNELL BATTLE
NATHALIE BEAUCHAMPS
GRIFFIN BOWEN BERLIN
LYDIA BURLESON
AAKSHI CHABA
SIMARPREET SINGH CHADHA
MARI MEKHI CHILES
CHIARA MICHAL NA-RI
CHUNG-HALPERN
MCKENZIE MARIE COOKE
KAITLYN NICOLE CORFMAN
KATHERINE LIVINGSTON CUTLER
NICHOLAS B. CUTLER, JR.
RAAJII CHOROKE DANIEL
KATE M. DONOVAN
DUSTIN KENT DUNAWAY
LENA H. GALLAGER
MARKOS GAZEPIS
ALINA JENNIFER MILA GLAUBITZ
MIA NKECHI JACKSON
GREGORY JANY
KIT YEE KAN
ANNA SOPHIA KANE
JAKE LAWRENCE KALODNER
MATTHEW JOSEPH LAMIRANDE
JOHNNY NGUYEN LE
TAESOO DANIEL LEE
KEVIN JI LI
HEIDI MAKHLOUF
CHARLES PAUL MARKERT
DIEGO MARTELL
SAMANTHA JAYNE MARTINELLI
NICHOLAS CHANDLER MARWELL
ALEXANDRA NICOLE MCCRAVEN
LUKE IAN MCKENNA
JILLIAN EVE MEHLMAN
LAUREN MORIYAMA
HANG PHUONG NGUYEN
JESUTOMI IBUKUNOLUWA ODUKOYA
CRISTINA BEATRIZ OTERO
JESSICA TAYLOR PEVNER
KHOI NGUYEN PHAM
TUAN BAO CHAU PHAM
LILY CORNELIA BRAINARD ROGERS
NICHOLAS SERRAMBANA
ADITI KRISHNI SHETTY
CALVIN BLAKE SOLOMON
SAPHIA SUAREZ
ALEXA SABRINA TSAY
VERA CHUNG VILLANUEVA
MILES XAVIER WAITS
EMMA LUISA WILSON
WAI PAN WONG
ANGELA XIAO
ALICE ZHAO
AND THE GRADUATES PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY
JENNIFER DUENAS,
MARK ANTHONY WINHOFFER
CONGRATULATIONS J.E. CLASS OF
2021!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE
HONOR
TO PRESENT CANDIDATES FROM
SILLIMAN COLLEGE FOR THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE. WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY OF
YALE COLLEGE AND APPROVED BY
THE
CORPORATION, DEAN CHUN WILL ASK
YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT TO
CONFER UPON THEM THESE DEGREES.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT PETER SALOVEY:
BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN ME,
I
SHALL CONFER UPON YOU THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN, AND SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU
TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
LEANNA BARLOW:
BROOKE CATHERINE MILOSH
THE BANNER BEARER OF SILLIMAN
COLLEGE.
CAMILA ANDREA TORO
AND
CORY MARK ZHOU
THE PROCESSION MARSHALS OF
SILLIMAN COLLEGE.
SE BIN AHN
SAMIR AL-ALI
AVERY L. ARENA
AURORA TAYLOR ASADORIAN
JYOT SINGH BATRA
DANIEL MATTHEW BLATT
NATALIE JANE BOYER
EMMA MARIE BRODEY
JOSEPH ANTONIO BROWNSBERGER
BRENDA SOPHIA CACHAY GUTIERREZ
CHELSEA MARIA CHAUG
KEVIN CHEN
KATHRYN D. CLULO
JESUS CONTRERAS MAGANA
ANDRE L. COSTA
JOHN ALEXANDER DEAN
OLIVIA DRUBNER
FARAH MARIE EMORY-MUHAMMAD
DARLENE LUZMARIA GOMEZ
KENIA DANELLE HALE
DEONTE DAMOND HENSON
SAMANTHA HIGGINS
STEPHANIE BOMA HORSFALL
LILLIAN HUA
JACOB KOPPELMAN HUTT
ROBERT WILLIAM JAHRLING
BRETT WILLIAM JEWELL
ANTHONY LIANG JI
SUNGMI ANNA JOHNSON
CHRISTINA KAO
CONOR JACOB KENNEDY
JP KENNEY
EMERY DAVID KEREKES
CAROLINE SOHYUN KIM
LAUREN KIM
NIKITA KLIMENKO
ALINE SOOCHUNG KO
MADELYN CHIU KUMAR
STANLEY ZHUN-LUNG LAM
ABIGAIL VIVIAN LEE
ARACELI A. LOPEZ
BRANDON LU
THOMAS DUKE MARTIN
MATTHEW BASSAM MASSAAD
PHYLLIS NOKUTHABA P. MUGADZA
ASANTE PAUL MZUNGU
GREGORY CONNOR NARATIL
MAGGIE K. NOLAN
EMILY EUNJUNG OH
SAMUEL BROOKS CALABRESI OLDSHUE
ALICE PARK
JORDAN CHRISTINE PILANT
WILLIAM R. POLSKY
IOANN POPOV
PETER PRASTAKOS
ANDREW JAMES ROCHON
CATHERINE JENS SAWKINS
BHAVESH SANDEEP SAYAL
LARA SCHULL
MEI SHINOMIYA
OLIVIA SHOEMAKER
VASILEIOS PLATON SIOUFAS
SLATER ADAMS SMITH
KELLY ANN SPELTZ
HRISTO SVETOSLAVOV STAYKOV
HENRY STEVEN SUCKOW ZIEMER
JAMES JIAN SUN
MARTIN DALY TIPTON
TEODORA ANGELOVA TYANKOVA
JENNA GRACE VAN DE GRIFT
RAM VISHWANATHAN
AARON JOSHUA WADE
TOM WALLENSTEIN
KENNETH WANG
XAVIER TARIQ WASHINGTON
THOMAS BAILEY WIESLER
JASON YANG
JENNIFER Y. YOON
DANA ZAMIR
MACIEJ J. ZIELONKA
THE GRADUATES PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY ARE:
FR
DARCY CHANIN
MPHO CALACHAN MOLEFE
QINYING SUN
CONGRATULATIONS SILLIMAN CLASS
OF 2021!
[ APPLAUSE ]
ALICIA SCHMIDT CAMACHO:
MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE THE HONOR
TO PRESENT CANDIDATES FROM EZRA
STILES COLLEGE FOR THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE. WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDED BY THE FACULTY OF
YALE COLLEGE AND APPROVED BY
THE
CORPORATION, DEAN CHUN WILL ASK
YOU BY YOUR OFFICIAL ACT TO
CONFER UPON THEM THESE DEGREES.
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> BY THE AUTHORITY VESTED IN
MY, I
SHALL CONFER UPON YOU THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN YALE
COLLEGE WHEN DESIGNATED BY THE
DEAN, AND SHALL THEN ADMIT YOU
TO ALL THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
COVERT JAMES GEARY, JR.
THE BANNER BEARER OF EZRA
STILES COLLEGE
GABRIELLA BLATT
AND
WANAHCA LUTA FAST DOG
THE PROCESSION MARSHALS OF EZRA
STILES COLLEGE.
GRACE ELLEN AARONSON
JACOB ANGELO ABDALLAH
ZAINAB OMOWONUOLA ENIOLA ABIOLA
ODUNOWO
JACK ADAM
ALESSANDRA SOFIA AGUIRRE
KATHERINE TERESA ARACKAPARAMBIL
BESSIE MARIA BAUMAN
BRITTANY MARIE BISTIS
SOFIA EVA BLIEK
GRETA KIRBY BROWNE
BRANDON ROBERT CANFIELD
MARTIN STUART CHANDLER
JOSEPH LEO CLASS
ALEXANDER NATHAN COHEN
NATHANIEL ALEXANDER CUEVAS
AIVY T. DUONG
IVY VICTORIA FAN
ALYSSA NICOLE FIRTH
VERONICA E. GALIMBERTI
RAYMOND LIU GAO
SIMON ALEXANDER GHEBREYESUS
ABIGAIL GERTRUDE GUNDRUM
GRANT THEODORE HALLIDAY II
ALONI BENNETTE HARRIS
CHARLES TOWNSEND HARDY HAWKINGS
JACQUELINE MERCEDES HAYRE-PÉREZ
PHILIP EDWARD HINKES
LOGAN MCCLANE HOWARD
CASSANDRA HSIAO
KATHERINE HU
ALEJANDRO ANTONIO JACO
EMILY YUANWEN JI
EMILY ELIZABETH JOHNSON
JAEGER MARIO JOHNSON
DAYRIN MESHACH LOUROME JONES
ZACHARY DAKOTA JONES
ALICIA KACHARIA
YUKI KAWAMURA
ANDREW PETER KUZEMCZAK
YOANNA PETROVA LAZAROVA
ISABEL JINHEE LEE
JIN HUA LI
EMILY LIN
LAURENCE DA XIAO LU
CAMERON MORGAN LUTHER
SARA JANE LUZURIAGA
SABRINA LYZ MACIAS
SAM C. MANISCALCO
TIA JACQUELINE MARESCA
JEVER KOHLI MARIWALA
MARY CLARE MCMAHON
BRITTANY MENJIVAR
KELLEN M. MERMIN-BUNNELL
ANNA GRAVES MILLIKEN
ANDI MO
MOHAMED HASSAN MOHAMUD
ISABEL MARIE MONROY
VIKRAM MULLICK
SOPHIA (JIHYE) NAM
JOSE M. NAVAS
PETER NEKRASOV
MAX DANIEL NOBEL
ALEXANDRIA BELLA NOBLE
CORAL LYN ORTIZ
NOLAN PATRICK PADIN
MARISA ALEXIS PERYER
KALEY G. PILLINGER
LORENZO PINASCO FERREYROS
ANDREW JORDAN VITA PRINSTER
IVANA PRSTIC
SAJAN NARAYANA RAMANATHAN
ESTHER REYES
KOBE JAMES RIZK
LAURIE ANNE ROARK
CAROLYN ELIZABETH JAE HEE SACCO
ISABEL SALINAS ARREOLA
EMILY HOPE SCHUSSHEIM
BENJAMIN COLE SHELTON
JOVAN MATTHEW TAFOYA
HELEN S. TEEGAN
RENEE JESSICA TUNG
ZACHARY LOGON WADE
SAMANTHA JIMENEZ WESTFALL
NIA ADERONKE WHITMAL
JONATHAN WU
EMILY HAN XU
CHETHAN SANJAY YADAV
ALEC GRAY ZBORNAK
ZIXUAN OASIS ZHEN
BENJAMIN KAIHUA ZHOU
CRISTOFER ZILLO
AND THE GRADUATES PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY
ERIN HONGJU CHOI
JASON ANDREW GOODE
HUAN HUAN HO
JOSEPH QUAN
GO EZRA STILES!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> TO THE STUDENTS OF THE CLASS
OF
2021 AND THEIR PARENTS,
FAMILIES, AND FRIENDS LOOKING
ON
FROM AROUND THE GLOBE: WE
GATHER
TO RECOGNIZE THE EXTRAORDINARY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF ALL OF YOU
WHO HAVE WORKED SO HARD TO
COMPLETE YOUR PROGRAMS OF
STUDY.
WE SALUTE YOUR EFFORTS, YOUR
DILIGENCE, YOUR TALENT, AND
YOUR
INTELLECT. WE ALSO JOIN YOU IN
EXPRESSING GRATITUDE FOR ALL
WHO
HAVE SUPPORTED YOU IN THESE
ENDEAVORS: YOUR FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS, TEACHERS, AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE YALE COMMUNITY.
CONGRATULATIONS, CLASS OF 2021!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> HELLO CLASS OF 2021!
MY NAME IS
STEVEN ORIENTALE, AND I AM A
MEMBER OF THE CLASS DAY
COMMITTEE AND THE SENIOR CLASS
COUNCIL.
FOUR YEARS HAVE GONE BY IN THE
BLINK OF AN EYE. WE'VE MADE SO
MANY MEMORIES, FROM THE
FIRST-YEAR SNOWBALL FIGHT ON
OLD
CAMPUS RIGHT HERE, TO THE
YALE-HARVARD
FOOTBALL GAME OF 2019 -- WHERE
WE WON IN DOUBLE-OVERTIME, TO
ALL OF THE LATE NIGHTS, WHETHER
THEY BE IN THE LIBRARY STUDYING
FOR AN EXAM OR IN THE COMMON
ROOMS TALKING WITH OUR FRIENDS
AND SUITEMATES.
ALTHOUGH OUR SENIOR YEAR
EXPERIENCE WAS CERTAINLY NOT A
TRADITIONAL ONE, THE CLASS OF
2021 MADE THE BEST OF THE
SITUATION. WHEN WE LEAVE YALE
IN
JUST A FEW DAYS, WE WILL LEAVE
WITH MEMORIES AND FRIENDSHIPS
THAT WILL LAST A LIFETIME.
HERE'S TO THE CLASS OF 2021! WE
DID IT!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> CLASS OF 2021, GOOD MORNING!
MY NAME IS STANLEY LAM.
>> AND I'M JINLI.
>> AND WE ARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THAT ORGANIZED
CLASS DAY, WHICH WILL AIR ON
YOUTUBE TOMORROW AT 2:30 P.M.
>>
TWO MINUTES BEFORE 2:30, AT
2:28
P.M., A SPECIAL PIECE WRITTEN
BY
CLASS DAY SPEAKER, ROBERT
LOPEZ,
WILL BE PLAYED FROM HARKNESS
TOWER, SO KEEP YOUR EARS OPEN.
>> IF YOU HAVEN'T ALREADY
DECORATED
A FUNNY HAT FOR CLASS DAY, IT'S
NOT TOO LATE.
>> IN FACT, ON YOUR
SEAT TODAY, YOU RECEIVED A
CLASS
DAY 2021 HAT THAT YOU MIGHT
WANT
JUST FOR THAT PURPOSE.
>> YOU'LL ALSO FIND A GIFT BAG,
WHICH
INCLUDES ITEMS THAT REPRESENT
LONGSTANDING CLASS DAY
TRADITIONS, AS WELL AS OTHERS
THAT ARE NEW AND UNIQUE TO THE
CLASS OF 2021.
>> IN ADDITION TO THE
THE CLASS DAY SPEAKER,
TOMORROW'S PROGRAM ALSO
INCLUDES
REMARKS BY MEMBERS OF OUR CLASS
WHO HAVE PUT TOGETHER
OUTSTANDING ORIGINAL SPEECHES.
>> AND BECAUSE CLASS DAY IS
ABOUT
ALL OF US, YOU'LL SEE YOUR
PHOTOGRAPHS AND VIDEO
REFLECTIONS THROUGHOUT
TOMORROW'S PROGRAM.
>> CONGRATULATIONS CLASS OF
2021.
AND SEE YOU AT CLASS DAY!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
DEAN MARVIN CHUN: CLASS OF
2021,
CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN.
I AM SO HAPPY
TO BE WITH YOU AND CELEBRATE
WITH YOU TODAY. GRADUATING IS A
GREAT ACCOMPLISHMENT, ONE OF
THE
MOST IMPORTANT ONES OF YOUR
LIFE. IF YOU THINK BACK TO WHEN
YOU FIRST ARRIVED ON CAMPUS, NO
ONE COULD HAVE IMAGINED THAT
YOU
WOULD LIVE THROUGH A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC BEFORE REACHING THIS
MOMENT. BUT YOU DID, AND THANKS
TO YOUR STRENGTH AND
PERSEVERANCE, THIS MOMENT HAS
FINALLY COME. I AM
HONORED TO RECOGNIZE ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU HAVE
DONE TO GET HERE, MUCH OF IT
WITH THE SUPPORT OF YOUR FAMILY
AND FRIENDS.
SO TODAY IS YOUR
DAY, AND IT IS THEIRS TOO.
TODAY IS A DAY FOR LOOKING
BACK WITH PRIDE AT EVERYTHING
YOU HAVE ACCOMPLISHED AND ALL
THE GOALS YOU HAVE REACHED. OF
COURSE IT BRINGS SOME SADNESS,
TOO, NOW THAT YOU ARE ENDING
YOUR BRIGHT COLLEGE YEARS. BUT
TODAY IS A COMMENCEMENT, A
BEGINNING, SO NOW, AS YOU LOOK
TO THE DAYS AND YEARS AHEAD,
THINK OF THE NEW ACHIEVEMENTS
AND OPPORTUNITIES IN FRONT OF
YOU. AND LOOK AROUND AS WELL,
TO
REMIND YOURSELF OF THE
EXCELLENT
COMPANY JOINING ON THIS NEW
BEGINNING ━ YOUR FRIENDSHIPS
FORMED AT YALE.
TOMORROW YOU WILL CELEBRATE
CLASS DAY ━ A TRADITION
STRETCHING BACK 150 YEARS IN
YALE COLLEGE HISTORY. I AM
EXCITED TO  WATCH THE VIRTUAL
PROGRAM ALONG WITH YOU, AND ON
MONDAY, WE CAN LOOK FORWARD TO
PRESIDENT SALOVEY'S
COMMENCEMENT ADDRESS.
I AM
GRATEFUL TO THE CLASS DAY
COMMITTEE, TO THE SENIOR CLASS
COUNCIL, TO THE UNIVERSITY'S
SECRETARY'S OFFICE, TO YOUR
COLLEGE HEADS AND DEANS, AND TO
EVERYONE WHO CONTRIBUTED TO
MAKING THE SPECIAL EVENTS
OF THIS WEEKEND
POSSIBLE. AND I'M MOST
APPRECIATIVE TO YOU, FOR ALL
THAT YOU HAVE BROUGHT TO YALE━-
AND WILL NOW BRING OUT INTO THE
WORLD WITH YOU. AGAIN, CLASS OF
2021, CONGRATULATIONS!
[  CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪